hey guys dr. Berg here in this short video
we're gonna talk about cataracts first of
all what is a cataract basically a clouded
lens your lens starts becoming cloudy to the
point where you can't see anymore and then
they have to do surgery so this happens in
the normal aging process a lot of stress side
effect from prednisone side-effect from having
too much insulin diabetics pre-diabetics insulin
resistance all these things are related to insulin
in general okay so there's two great remedies
that you can get I'll put some links down below
I don't recommend any brands but I'll just kind
of tell you the form that you need because you
need a special type of fat soluble vitamin b1
normally b1 comes in a water-soluble but being
fat soluble it penetrates the cell membrane to
get deep into the eye to help repair cataracts
this is really really good also for peripheral
neuropathies anything related to nerve issues
but you know a diabetic usually kind of goes
blind eventually because of the depletion of
the what glucose does to the depletion of b1 so
putting that back in can really help your vision
and so you have to get into fat soluble form
the next one is NAC drops n-acetylcarnosine
this is another great remedy that you can take
and drop so you can get it anywhere I'll put a
link down below and you can start to use that to
repair the lens of the eye but of course don't
forget to get your diet squared away to fix this
and this right here okay and I created videos
on that as well I'll put some links down below
alright go ahead and put your comments down below